what's up everyone it's Warren and we
have a new Avengers in-game leaked today
this one about Ironman I know this leak
in particular will make some fans very
happy because it's a toy leaked but it's
a pop Ironman bobblehead
just a reminder only one day left in my
IMAX ticket giveaway the winner will
receive five imax tickets so you and
some friends can go see either Captain
Marvel or Avengers in-game in IMAX if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel with the notifications turned
on like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain ok so an
Iron Man pop leak and look what he's
wearing
of course he's wearing his white suit
which many people are calling right now
his advance tech suit and which many
people believe to be a quantum realm
suit we've learned from ant-man that you
need a special type of suit to travel
inside of the quantum realm but some
people think that Iron Man's armor
should still be enough to travel in the
quantum room but if you refer back to
ant-man and the wasp Hank Pym at one
point says this isn't some stark tech so
it's very clear that there is a specific
suit that you use to go inside of the
quantum room and many people believe
that Iron Man with the help of Scotland
and Bruce Banner will build these suits
for all of the Avengers go inside of the
quantum realm and go back in time now
there have been many leaks in the past
where we've seen some of these Avengers
wearing these white suits but despite
all of these leaks that we've gotten toy
leaks promo art leaks some people still
think they're fake they're clearly not
and I think this is sort of the final
piece that solidifies the fact that they
are real because this is a very
legitimate leak this is a Tony Stark pop
figure and it's clear that he's wearing
the suit now on the cover of the box
he's wearing a white and black suit but
the actual figure is wearing more of a
white and blue suit and that is probably
because as you can see on the front of
the box it says that it glows in the
dark and this is most likely the part
that glows also take note of what is on
his left hand one of the bracelets that
we've seen Iron Man Ant Man and Captain
America wearing in some leaked set
photos these are the devices that
everybody believes will help the
Avengers go inside of the quantum realm
and travel back in time considering that
the leaked photos that we saw were of
the
vengers in the original Battle of New
York implying that the Avengers have
traveled back in time so it looks like
as more and more leaks come out we're
going to get a little bit more
information about what to expect in
Avengers in game like I said at this
point in time it's pretty hard to argue
that these leaked suits are real there's
just been way too much evidence pointing
to the fact that they are real from
leaks and merchandise coming out I fully
expect for us to see these suits in
Avengers in game when it comes out in
theaters so let me know what you think
about this leak and let me know what you
think about these new white suits that
the Avengers will be using in Avengers
in game let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment down below
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you